the eh-2-zed of isms neoliberalism
Friedrich Hayek a Tweedy austrian-born
economist had one of those light bulb
moments in the mid 1930s and switched on
an ideology that unites its enemies in
scorn that has inspired governments and
entrepreneurs down the decades
neoliberalism the idea was built on the
classical liberalism of the 18th century
and a defense of individual liberty
protecting private property and the
freedom of markets from external
interference taxes regulations levies as
much as possible neoliberalism argued
that the market wasn't just an absence
of interference it could produce a
philosophy or a way of thinking all of
its own that meant looking at the world
and our transactions in daily life
through the eyes of the market you can
glimpse this for instance when I say I'm
in the market for a beer showing that
we've internalized the idea of a market
for other values nowadays you probably
hear the word neoliberalism used more as
a term of abuse hurled by opponents that
economic globalizes and nasty bankers or
governments limiting spending on public
works or welfare the word neo or new has
morphed into a way of signaling I don't
like this one bit
it's the nearest thing economic
terminology has to a rotten tomato
but neoliberalism isn't just a dirty
word it's an entire mind set of
approaches to the way state and market
interact with our aspirations
emphasizing privatization over state
control as the best way to deliver
public services the advent of
neoliberalism led to one of the great
punch ups of economists between Hayek
and his best frenemies John Maynard
Keynes Keynes argued that government
should get involved in increasing demand
to keep productivity up and unemployment
down
Hayek dismissed Keynes as knowing very
little about economics and he wrote a
snotty book review of one of Keynes's
major works despite their bickering
though their competing ideas
Keynesianism and neoliberalism remain
the seesaw of big thinking in practical
economics Keynesian isn't one for good
while after World War two but by the end
of the 1970s public sector strikes and
worries about stagflation an ugly combo
of stagnation and inflation persuaded
some world breakers to look back to
neoliberalism as a way to perk up
flagging economies Ronald Reagan and
Margaret Thatcher led the way in
embracing the notion and so little
ruthless dictator Augusto Pinochet in
Chile which rather marked down the
democratic scorecard of neoliberalism
the financial crash of 2007 8 created a
mold testing mood towards deregulation
and neoliberalism games about rep
because it was taxpayers who had to bail
out the banks but there's a broader
cultural reason neoliberalism gets it in
the neck right now inevitably it leads
to such fast-paced uncontrolled
globalization because it does away with
barriers to trade and to financial flows
it prizes the innovative above
continuities so you could say it puts
the corporation above the nation but the
globalized world we inhabit one of
startups the ability to move money and
borrow cheaply and companies operating
across borders owes a lot to the
austrian friedrich hayek and his
lightbulb moment
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon